that's some reaction now to the expanded
probe of the president senior political
analyst Brit Hume is here tonight good
evening Brett your thoughts generically
about this launch the flurry of
documents for requests well I don't
think it's any accident Brett that this
is coming at a time when there's
widespread expectation that Muller is
about finished his job and as he's doing
that there doesn't appear to be many
people now who any longer think that he
will come up with some kind of
conspiracy theory related to collusion
by the Trump campaign with the Russians
similarly there seems to be some doubt
that he will make any kind of
allegations to the effect that the
President himself obstructed justice
although you heard Jerrold Nadler say
that he thinks there's lots of evidence
of that or he thinks it's clear that
that's true if he did why not move right
to impeachment well obviously he doesn't
have the evidence of that so the search
is on for something else really they may
try to figure out some kind of a
obstruction of justice charge but it
appears they're moving away from
collusion and I think Brett that there's
some thought that Muller because he's
not going to indict on collusion or
conspiracy to collaborate or whatever
may say nothing about that at all I
don't think that's true I think he's
bound to say something about it or at
least report something about it to the
Attorney General because that was part
of his original charge motors original
charge was to investigate that among
several other things so I think he'll
reach the conclusions about that and
they will become public and if they
don't say anything incriminating about
the president on that score I wonder you
know how much wind will remain in the
sails of that charge and some others
yeah I mean it's important to point out
we don't know what we don't know and the
process does you rightly point out goes
to the Attorney General and when that
happens we don't know there are other
investigations the Southern District of
New York for example looking at serious
allegations against the the financing
and the Trump Organization but is your
sense that this is kind of the Democrats
looking for another ace in the hole yeah
that's what it looks like to me is that
they've you know for the longest time as
you we've been buried under these
allegations and all this speculation
the Trump was greatly aided by the
Russians and a grand conspiracy to throw
him the election and if that doesn't pan
out you know the public has heard all
this - I think it's a good question how
well the public will receive a lot of
continuing investigations on other
matters you know it's certainly possible
that the Southern District of New York
and charge could come up with criminal
allegations against the president for
the way he conducted his business but
Justice Department policy does not allow
for indictment for that while the
president is in office and it's are not
clear to me either Bret that an
impeachment would make any sense because
impeachment I think it's clearly
intended for things that are done by a
president while he's in office so you
know this is gonna be he said he's gonna
be under a ton of document requests and
it's gonna be continuing hearings and
investigations and sound and fury about
all this but how far it will go if
Muller doesn't come up with something
big I think it's a good question and
there is politically a risk/reward
moment here for Democrats because as you
rightly point out we're heading into the
2020 cycle already having candidates out
on the trail if the president were to
lose the election that's how we would
get kicked out of office and we always
seem like we're one election away from
solving the big thing so Democrats have
to make a calculation whether it's all
investigations or it's actually
legislation at some point well that's
right I mean it you know there's only so
much oxygen in the atmosphere at any
given moment in politics and if
Democrats are gonna be sucking it all up
with with an endless round of
investigations and and the circus-like
hearings like the one we had last week
you know it's not clear to me that they
can build the case that they will need
to build to try to legislate or to biess
notice legislating because then all the
reporting is gonna be about something
else not all of it but but most of it so
I think you're right Brett that there
has to be some kind of a calculation as
to what's what's better politically to
investigate or attempt to legislate even
if they don't pass things and get them
to get them signed if they pass a lot of
bills that the president has to veto or
get blocked in the Senate those are all
those be then become issues that they
Democrats can run on as a way to get to
get you know their candidates and their
presidential candidate elected in 2020
all right Brett as always we're looking
at all the document requests out there
so be fascinating to cover them
appreciate it